Nick Nolte who's amazing that was the
movie
you didn't get to work with Nolte though
I didn't but I hung out with him the
whole time he actually changed my life
nicknote how because Nick up until then
I was like I think whatever you know you
learn your lines you go do it and I'm
like whatever I'm just doing stupid [__]
and he had this binder with now Nick is
like the Mad professor in real life he's
smart oh my God and he's got this giant
binder with like papers and flies and
all kinds of [__] moving around right
and I was like Nick one day I just sat
there and go what do you what is in
there what is in there right I said
that's my character what so I uh over
the course of like two or three months
we were there a long time in Pittsburgh
he kind of taught me how to break down a
script the way he does it and the way he
broke down a character in a way he and
it was and he still does it and he still
does it it changed my career it changed
my life it changed the way I looked at
acting I thought acting was kind of
silly I still do but I understand I
understand how to do it in in a far
deeper way because of Nick Nolte and he
got nominated for an Oscar in that movie
yeah yeah but it's amazing that you
actually wanted to take that advice to
take that sort of work ethic yeah you
know because that that takes another
level like do you want to work that hard
because like you go on set you deliver
your lines you're always good like you
know what else what do I need naturally
I'm making money I got kids I got a life
right you know right so the fact that
you said hey I'm gonna do that and now
you do this for every movie yeah deep
and by the way I've I've kind of almost
like like it's almost got me in trouble
on several occasions because I figure
everybody should be working this way and
I got neurotic about it you know and now
I've cooled out a bit because who cares
and uh but it really was it really
became an interesting way to work it was
really a lot of fun and you realize how
many people are lazy when you are the
guy doing the work wow yeah